you've all heard the phrase before can't
be the boss and bloodborne get good not
fast enough to out tonight someone in
battlefield get good shoelace is untied
get good people have used it jokingly
and sometimes seriously for a while and
the latest game to embody its sentiment
is none other than the colorful 1930s
cartoon inspired
cuphead people are calling it the dark
souls of platformers which is actually
quite fitting not just because you're
literally collecting the souls of your
enemies but also because of the game's
boss rush design everyone the bosses
presents unique challenges that will
test your skills reactions and
multitasking abilities they're comprised
of several different phases with each
phase posing new and completely
different obstacles than the last some
people might not find any enjoyment out
of dying over and over but for cuphead
that's the exact way the game should be
played if each boss had mechanics simple
enough to beat a blind in one go the
challenge obviously wouldn't be there
but more importantly the game would lack
the very real sense of accomplishment
and satisfaction that defeating one of
its many bosses gives you
the way each battle is structured
encourages you to die learn from your
mistakes and come back swinging in the
next rematch the game teaches you each
section slowly and once you've figured
out how to navigate the bullet hell in
one phase and are able to get past it
you immediately get the sense of
fulfillment it's very much like a really
good sneeze a satisfying release but you
are also left with a mess immediately
afterwards since the boss will change
things up and you'll have to learn the
next part in the same manner you can
call it masochism or whatever you want
but in my opinion the game never really
becomes a vehicle for frustration every
death takes you immediately back to the
start no loading required and the
tantalizing thought of completing the
level is teased with the timeline
tracking your progress yes you may die
to a boss several dozen times over and
over retry after every stupid mistake as
you slowly lose track of time and
suddenly it's 4 a.m. and you should
definitely be sleeping but I mean in all
fairness time is just a human construct
put in place to keep people like us from
playing more Cup head
[Music]
maybe the best way to describe the game
would be difficult but fair as hazards
rarely if ever feel unavoidable there
can be a lot of moving parts within each
encounter and even if there are a bunch
of things going on at once they each
tend to be straightforward and
consistent for example this one blimp
will always spit out a single projectile
at you while this other blimp will
always spit out several in the same
pattern and the boss will always laugh
in the same direction so these things
alone are easily avoidable but when you
combine them all you have a recipe for
the scathing difficulty that becomes a
lifeblood of the entire game but unlike
some other games that are difficult just
for difficulties sake couple approaches
the dreaded trial and error concept with
Grace and finesse and never once
punishes you for doing the right thing
you may die to a stray ghosts eyeball or
a razor-sharp feather but unlike you and
your skill those things never change
between fights figuring out the bosses
mechanics on your own applying them and
taking them down because you had the
spatial awareness to avoid all the crap
thrown at you is what the game is all
about the learning process may be
daunting for some but when you succeed
it's a supremely gratifying and
immensely rewarding experience that
makes all the deaths that came before it
or at the time
[Music]
hey guys I hope you liked this short
take on Cup heads difficulty it's one of
my personal favorites of the entire year
and I hope that you find some time to at
least give it a shot even if it's not
your bag if you have played it I want to
hear about it in the comments below I
want to hear favorite bosses least
favorite bosses the most vs thing in the
game let me know what you think and
don't forget to check out the review of
the game over on GameSpot calm and I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]